dans les commentaires aujourd'hui il ya
une sorte de commentaires ce qui
consiste à dire ce président font
manquerez manquerait de courage
très honnêtement est-ce qu'il ya eu dans
l'histoire de la république un président
qui a décidé pour l'intérêt de la france
de mener une politique dont il savait
par avance qu'elle était aussi difficile
quand vous rentrez dans un quinquennat
en disant aux français
la situation est-elle je vais vous
demander de faire des efforts c'est à
dire de payer des impôts supplémentaires
que je vais être obligé d'en réduire la
démo la dépense publique ce qui est pas
et souvent moins facile je suis dit
c'est le courage c'est pas des mots
c'est des actes et un président de la
république qui se dit que l'intérêt
supérieur de la france c'est de mener
cette politique je suis assez surpris
qu'on puisse lui contester le courage
vous savez le courage en politique il se
mesure justement dans la possibilité et
dans la détermination de prendre des
décisions qui sont les décisions que la
situation exige